mind your elbow job Hawkeye
look at you
welcome back everybody it's Charlie we
got a whole bunch of new Marvel phase 4
to talk about we just found out who's
gonna be the next Hawkeye and Marvel
phase 4 so we'll break it down there's
new giveaway stuff I'll explain at the
end of the video if you're brand new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get
all the easter-egg videos there's gonna
be so much stuff happening in the next
couple of months a lot of you saw that
scene of Hawkeye teaching his daughter
to shoot the bow saying good job Hawkeye
high-fiving her before they turned into
dust and assume maybe that's an easter
egg for Kate Bishop maybe she'll become
the next version of Hawkeye rewatching
it now we obviously know that's not the
case although I do think they were
trying to foreshadow Kate Bishop Hawkeye
in the Hawkeye solo series but now we
know who the actual new Hawkeye is going
to be if you didn't see the news
starting with number 5 Hailee Steinfeld
was just announced as Marvel's new Kate
Bishop the person who Clint Barton
Hawkeye is going to train during the
Hawkeye series it's a huge win for
marble she was just in transformers
bumblebee but she also just did
coincidence
a movie with Nick Fury himself samuel
l.jackson where he trains her as an
assassin called barely lethal what a
coincidence
this is a clip of her beating the crap
out of sophie Turner
[Music]
so the whole idea there is that she's
just an actress who can do comedy in
action and you need to be able to do
both to fill that Kate Bishop Hawkeye
role even though technically Cape Bishop
comes from a very different background
from Hawkeye they share a lot of
personality traits for what about
crossing over with the next Avengers
movies there are enough Marvel phase 4
projects set on earth right now that she
could always cameo in a movie before to
the hawkeye's series spider-man Civil
War style because the release date for
that Hawkeye series is October November
2021 probably closer to October because
it's supposed to come out before Thor
for love and thunder and that's coming
out at the beginning of November they
won't start shooting the series till
later next year unless they want to move
things up in the schedule
Hawkeye episodes are supposed to start
right after the Avengers what if
episodes end I don't think any of these
big Marvel phase 4 shows schedules are
gonna overlap just a steady stream of
new episodes for what seems like 26
weeks out of the year with a few breaks
in between not including the movies I
will be doing videos for all that stuff
obviously it's still pretty early days
right now but all the TV series they're
working on are supposed to crossover
with the movies influence the plot of
the movies set big things up both
villains and heroes so the Hawkeye
series is basically getting Cape Bishop
Hailee Steinfeld up to snuff in time for
Avengers 5 unless they want to cross her
over with Thor for love and thunder
which I'm not expecting blade I guess
you could show up in blade or black
panther 2 but probably not and she could
always cross over with the Moon Knight
series Miss Marvel or she-hulk because
those are a little more ground-level and
they're set on planet earth mostly the
series is just getting her ready as
Hawkeye for Avengers 5 in Young Avengers
3 what's the actual story of the series
we all know based on what Kevin Feige
and Marvel have said that it's going to
be inspired by Matt Fraction Hawkeye run
my life is a weapon that's Hawkeye vol 4
if you want to read that it's a no
brainer it's a great story they'll have
to make some big changes to that story
to account for how different MCU Hawkeye
is from comic book Hawkeye because movie
has a family he's trying to retire to be
with them just to go off and live on his
farm for the rest of his days maybe
clear a little of the read off of his
ledger that he accumulated as Ronan
during Avengers endgame Kevin Feige did
reveal that the Hawkeye solo series will
reveal more of his time when he was
Ronan during Avengers endgame in that
five-year time jump mostly that's him
just mowing criminals down all over
planet Earth that did not get snapped
how dare you survive in my family the
innocent people gets snapped basic
backstory for Cape Bishop though is that
she grew up in a wealthy family her
father had ties to the mob eventually
she started to get curious investigated
him followed him to a meet up with the
mop and one of the people that was his
contacts she was caught held for ransom
then saved by Hawkeye of the Avengers
who she had never met before she admired
him for what he did aspired to be like
him but didn't really take the Hawkeye
name until after she was with the Young
Avengers which came way way later while
she was with that young Avengers team
they called her a whole bunch of
different names
she wore a costume that was inspired by
mockingbirds costume they called her
Hawk s mockingbird Hawk get tasks
mistress Hawking bird lady Hawkeye they
kind of turned her codename into a bit
of a joke because she's a wisecracker
just like Clint Barton she didn't really
start spending a lot of time teaming up
with Hawkeye until Marvel Civil War
Secret Invasion and then a couple other
stories happen but then you get the
fraction run where Hawkeye recruits her
to help take down a group of low-level
criminals based on circus tropes so it's
this nice balance of really hardcore
action of them just mowing through all
these criminals and wisecracking along
the way telling a bunch of jokes their
next adventure was saving a little girl
then Madame masque kidnaps
Clint Barton and Kate Bishop has to go
save him so it becomes Kate Bishop
versus Madame masque after all the stuff
with Clint Barton Hawkeye she goes back
to the Young Avengers for some bigger
adventures so you can imagine how
they're gonna paste that TV show out
over the course of those six episodes
show her backstory with her family
Hawkeye probably saves her life at some
point she decides to get combat training
goes solo Hawkeye notices her and agrees
to eventually train her is
literally the plot of the Karate Kid
only instead of Johnny being the final
boss fight its Madame masque but because
they have so many villains to pick from
they might choose another big boss for
her to face during that series - you
probably just saw the news they hired
their showrunner he's one of the writers
from Mad Men so it sounds like the
writing is gonna be pretty solid they'll
change a lot of the plot of that
fraction run but it's still a really
good template this doesn't mean the
Clint Barton Hawkeye is going to die
they're gonna kill him off or he's never
going to come back in the Marvel movies
it just means that he's slowly
transitioning to a more background role
and he'll probably appear in cameos and
future Avengers movies but not in the
really really big way that you've seen
him in the last couple of Avengers films
not Avengers infinity war because he sat
that one out we actually found out why
he sat that out he actually just said
that he filmed so many movies that he
wanted to take a break before they
filmed Avengers end game so Jeremy
Renner himself specifically asked Marvel
to write him out of Avengers infinity
war originally I guess he was gonna have
a big role during that movie so mystery
solved it wasn't that they didn't want
to include Hawkeye it was that he didn't
want to be in that movie he just wanted
a little break before they did Avengers
end game number one though what about
Hailee Steinfeld is spider-gwen in the
Sony universe a lot of you were asking
this question on my Twitter yesterday
she was the voice of spider-gwen in the
animated spider-man into the
spider-verse movie she's supposed to be
in the sequel to that that they're
working on right now there's no release
date for that animation takes way longer
than live-action so it could be a couple
years before that happens but there was
still talk that Sony was gonna do an
animated spider-gwen spin-off movie with
her and because they just announced that
they were developing six new live-action
spider-verse TV shows the thought was
that she could always wind up playing
the live-action version of spider-gwen
in a TV show now that she's gonna be
doing this Hawkeye series in the Marvel
movies like she's literally gonna be in
the big Marvel phase for Marvel phase
five movies that's probably not going to
affect any of her work as animated
spider-gwen in the spider-man into the
spider-verse sequels she can still do
that mahuri lolly mr. Blade himself now
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe was
also in the animated spider-man into the
spider burst movie as miles as uncle the
Prowler
like hey so if my Hershel ollie can be
in the Netflix Marvel series be in a
Sony spider-man movie then become a huge
character in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and get his own movie then
Hailee Steinfeld can probably do the
same thing too but this does probably
mean that Hailee Steinfeld is out of the
running for any potential live-action
spider-gwen movies or TV shows because
Amy Pascal also said Sony was
considering live-action spider-man into
the spider-verse
but it's so far off who knows when
that's going to happen because right now
they still have the four spider-man
movies that they're trying to complete
with Tom Hollands that's spider-man 3
then spider-man 4 which is probably
gonna wind up being their big venom
crossover maybe a build up to maximum
carnage in the third venom movie then
after that is probably when they would
try some live-action spider-man into the
spider verse if everything goes well for
them but everybody post her reactions to
Hailee Steinfeld kate bishop hawkeye in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe I feel
like she's a pretty solid pick they're
probably couple people that could have
done that role but she's a really big
get for Marvel so it'll be fun to see
her beef up and throw down with some of
the big Marvel villains there's a lot of
you that have asked about what's going
on with the Young Avengers movie now
because obviously spider-man could have
been a part of that even though there's
all this Sony marble stuff going on it's
not over til it's over but they're still
obviously going to do a young Avengers
movie at some point they still have most
of the characters already based on what
they've announced funny enough a lot of
people around avengers endgame we're
also theory crafting the Kathryn
Langford mystery roll was going to be
future Kate Bishop until they revealed
that she was going to be the future
version of Tony Stark's daughter so
that's why you're seeing all this fan
art of Kathryn Langford is Kate Bishop
because it was from before they
announced that news we're doing a new
Amazon giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave your
best Hawkeye theory on the video
everybody leave your video requests in
the comments below
congratulations to best in 8 life you're
the giveaway winner from my last big
Marvel video please email me on the
about page of my channel so I can get
your details you do that on desktop I
don't think that that shows up on mobile
everybody click here for my non-spoilery
joker movie review and click here to
learn all about the new Wolverine vs.
Hulk project that Marvel is a
working on thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]